PROFESSOR: Welcome.
In this session, we're going
to examine pole diagrams.
So let's consider the pole
diagrams for the linear
time-independent systems
of the form p(D)y equals f.
So here, we have a
few pole diagrams
to examine with the poles
marked with the red crosses.
The axes are imaginary
axis and the real axis.
And the questions are list
all the stable systems.
Choose the systems
with the fastest decay.
And last, choose fastest
decay without oscillation.
So you have to think of how
to interpret these diagrams
and what are the meanings of the
position of the different poles
to address these questions.
So pause the video.
Take a few minutes.
And I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So the first question asks us
to list all the stable systems.
So if you recall, all
the stable systems
would be the ones for which
the real part of the pole
are all negative.
So if we have all the poles
with real part negative,
we would have a stable
system for which
the solution after a long
time would decay, basically.
It would be transient.
So here, if we look
at our pole diagrams,
we have diagram B for which
the real part of the two poles
are minus 3 and minus 2.
So this would
definitely generate
a decaying exponential,
exponential minus 2t,
exponential minus 3t type
function at large time
for this system.
In A, we have a minus 1 and a 1.
So the real part
here would give us
a decay, an exponential
decay, exponential minus t.
But we would have
here a term that will
diverge with exponential t.
So this would have basically
behavior at long time
that diverges and
doesn't go to 0.
So this would not, basically,
be a stable system.
For C, we have all the
real parts negative.
So we're in the stable case.
For D, we also have the same.
All the real parts are negative.
So these are imaginary,
3i-- minus 2 plus 3i.
So both of them have
also negative real parts.
Everything is on the
left side of the plane.
Same thing for E.
And for F, we're
right on the
imaginary axis, which
means that we can't
tell if it's going
to be an exponential--
it's not going
to be an exponential decay
or growth at this point.
So to answer the first
question, the stable systems
would be B, C, D,
E, and that's it.
So now, for the second
part, choose the system
with the fastest decay.
So here, again, as we just
saw, the real part of the poles
gives us the speed at which
the system is going to decay.
And so we have to
look for a system that
has its pole on the
rightmost part of the plane.
So for example, if we
restrict ourselves here,
the fastest decay here
is going to be governed
by the rightmost pole,
so exponential minus 2t,
that we need to examine.
Here, we have an exponential
minus 3t decay time.
Here, we would have an
exponential minus t decay.
Here, we would have something
a little bit-- minus 0.5t.
And here, again, this
is not stable system,
with a decay at large time.
So which of the system
has the fastest decay?
We would need to select the one
with the rightmost pole that
is the most on the left.
So we would need to compare
this minus 2, with this minus 3,
with this minus 1,
with this minus 0.5.
And from all these poles, the
one that has the minus 3 here
would be the one that would
be decaying the fastest.
So we would have system C
decaying as exponential minus
3t.
And I'm going to just
write down the others.
And these would be
the dominant terms
that would basically subscribe
the behavior at large t.
So this is the fastest.
For our system B, which
is not the fastest,
I'm just going to
write it, it's going
to be dominated by a minus 2t.
For the system D, it would
be dominated by a minus 1t.
For the system E, it would be
dominated by the minus 0.5t.
So the fastest decay would
definitely be system C.
So the last question,
choose the fastest decay
without oscillations.
So now, we need to pay attention
to whether the poles are
on the imaginary axis,
on the real axis,
or somewhere in the middle.
So let's again, examine
only the stable cases.
So here, the two poles
are in the real axis.
So it's going to give
us a behavior that
is only pure decay, exponential
decay, exponential minus
2t, exponential minus
3t, with no oscillation.
Because basically,
these two people
don't have any imaginary parts.
Here, we have a term in
exponential minus 3t.
But we would have a term
that would show oscillations
with the circular
frequencies of 3.
So you would have an
exponential minus 3t cosine 3t
plus exponential minus
3t sine 3t, for example.
So here, we would have a
system that shows oscillation.
So we don't want that.
For this case, that
would be similar.
So you see the pattern.
Here, we have an
exponential decay.
Here, we would have
decaying oscillations.
So there is oscillations.
Same thing here.
And so we're left with only
system B, which basically
does not show any oscillation
but only an exponential decay.
Pure decay.
And it's dominated by
the exponential minus 2t
without oscillations.
So that ends this first
part of the problem.
I'm just going to take
a minute and come back
to show you the second
part of the problem.
Welcome back for the
second part of the problem.
So here, another pole
diagram that we're going
to label J for this system.
And the poles are
basically here,
0.5 plus 4i, 0.5 minus 4i.
And then here, we
have almost a minus 3.
And here, it would be a minus 4.
So the question is to consider
now the previous system we had,
p of D y equals f of t.
But now, with f of t equals
F_0 cos omega*t, and omega,
the circular frequency
going between 1 and 5.
And the question is for
which values of omega
do we have the largest
response from the system G?
So basically, we're looking
at phenomenon of resonance
where we want to
find the frequency
omega for which the
response of the system
is going to be the biggest.
So I give you just
a few minutes,
and we'll be right back.
Welcome back for
this second part.
So here, if you recall,
the amplitude response from
the previous recitations, the
amplitude is governed by 1 over
the characteristic polynomial
evaluated at i*omega.
Where does i omega come from?
If you recall, it comes from the
exponential response formula.
Because on the right-hand side
here, we have a cosine omega*t,
then we complexify, exponential
i*omega*t, et cetera,
to get the amplitude response.
So the amplitude is going to
be the largest for basically
values of i*omega that are
the closest to the poles
of the polynomial-- to the
poles of this function.
Basically, the poles of the 1
over characteristic polynomial
is going to give
us the 1 over 0,
which will give an amplitude
response that goes to infinity,
so the largest response.
So we want to choose
our frequency, i*omega.
Basically, we want to
look at this diagram
and look at the poles that are
the closest to the values that
are going to give us
p of s equals to 0.
And this is basically
diagram that gives us
the pole of this 1 over p.
And so we want to choose
a value for i*omega,
which will be on
the imaginary axis,
that is the closest to
one of these two poles.
Given that we work with positive
frequencies, we would want,
for example, to choose
i*omega equals i*4.
So it would be here, or
just omega equals to 4.
And this value of
omega would get
us very close to this
pole, which would mean then
that we are 1 over a
very small number, which
means that the amplitude
response will be the biggest.
So that's the idea--
look behind the resonance
and looking at,
again, the phenomenon
of the resonance from the
pole diagram perspective
and with the idea of the
use of the Laplace transform
behind the whole technique.
So that ends this session.
And the goal was really
to learn to interpret
the meaning of the poles
in the pole diagram
and how do the polls
give us an idea
and insight on the behavior of
the system in the long term.